hallo herr fischer und so verlief welt
heute haben wir etwas zu verkünden im
titel habt ihr bereits gelesen und zwar
gibt es als meine eigene pflanze sendung
die ganzen jahre über muss ich euch auch
schon sagen als ich hab auch schon vor
drei oder vier jahren war doch mal ein
video gemacht
wie würdet ihr euch eine fernsehsendung
mit mir wünschen und weitergebildet ihr
euch vorstellen und wir hatten echt in
den letzten jahren auch sehr viel
angebote im prinzip einfach von allen
sendern also von allen die ihr
wahrscheinlich auch alle kennt private
öffentliche egal welche sender auch
immer und bisher haben wir das ganze
angebot noch abgelehnt weil es einfach
nicht zu uns gepasst hat entweder war
schon so dass ich irgendwie weit weg
hätte ziehen müssen nach köln oder nach
münchen oder nach berlin
und das ist für mich einfach nicht
vereinbar mit familie und ich bin bei
euch geben im schwabenland
und ich will eigentlich auf meinem
schönen warten wird zum dank nicht weg
und auch heute natürlich und deswegen
war das bisher immer nicht gut geeignet
für mich und dann war's auch immer so
dass in den fernsehsendungen im drehbuch
vorgegeben war eben eine geschichte die
erfunden wurde oder noch erfunden worden
wäre und es hat einfach nicht gepasst
also dieses künstliche geschichte
erfinden um drama zu erzeugen das ist
einfach nicht
das hat mich gepasst und wir wollten
nicht irgendwie künstlich emotionen
wecken und war nicht so weit
das heißt da haben wir auch immer auch
gesagt und das dritte war immer der
dritte punkt es wird von mir verlangt
dass ich dinge benutze oder dinge sage
oder auch lebensmittel verwenden die ich
sonst nie benutzt hätte oder auch
produkte in der küche um einfach ein
produkt zu platzieren sie wollten
sozusagen die vermarktungsrechte und das
macht auch nicht meint weil ihr kennt
mich ich habe in der küche meine geräte
ich bin uns die lebensmittel sich kenne
probiere gerne neue ist auch so ist es
nicht aber ich möchte ich einfach
irgendetwas benutzen weil dann das
fernsehsender dafür geld bekommt klar da
muss ich auch finanzieren aber ich
wollte mich einfach nicht verstellen und
nicht einfach irgendwas benutzen was mir
vorgeschrieben wird
ja deswegen haben wir die ganzen jahre
über die
sendungen immer abgesagt und weil wir
nicht wussten ja eben und salate zu
sagen es vor vier jahren habe ich das
video gemacht da fand ich noch mega
aufregend in der fernsehsendung zu
machen und ich hab damals jetzt nichts
cooleres gegeben mittlerweile sechstes
bisschen anders ich fahre jetzt auch
dann mit dem fernsehsender zusammen und
die haben mich dann auch gefragt ja
warum möchtest du die sendung und ich
habe dann gesagt ich möchte eigentlich
gar nicht ihr wollt doch mit mir eine
und weil einfach im moment alles sehr
gut läuft also wir können von zu hause
aus um von youtube videos produzieren
ich mache meine bücher her
samira fängt auch bald mit der schule an
allem im kindergarten und wir bauen ja
jetzt das heißt wir haben hier immer
alles vor ort bei uns und haben uns aber
mit einem kleinen sender tatsächlich
einigen können und zwar hat der gesagt
hätte wir sehen das genauso video wir
möchten auch kein drehbuch vorschreiben
wir müssen wir möchten die keine
produkte geben sondern bleibt einfach so
wie du bist mache im prinzip eine
youtube sendung aber fürs fernsehen und
wir können das ganze von zu hause aus
produzieren und was der oberhammer ist
finde ich
ich kann einfach mein ganzes team
verwählt als auch nicht verwenden ich
kann mit meinem team noch ausweiten der
turnhalle marius männer
die werden in zukunft als die
fernsehsendung produzieren und wie sieht
ihr das schon übrigen seien jetzt
aufgeregt ich alles in hand gehen von
dem sozusagen
wir haben es im haus erst selber alle
absichten müssen die haben waren hier
alles angeschaut die jungs geredet
wir machen es einfach genau
und ja ich freue mich schon richtig
drauf weil sich im prinzip für uns nicht
so viel ändert außer dass eben dann die
sendung was aber ein neuer in haus und
wissen wird angeführt ist es nicht so
dass ich einfach ein rezept mache
sondern ich mach ein rezept ohne
pakistan oder coole geschichte außen rum
und zwar spielen
ja ja aber was ich muss nur sagen sie zu
spielen auch eine rolle sagen was man so
lasst uns mal offen wer davon noch nicht
verraten möchte ich auch noch gar nicht
das volk dann in ein paar wochen
und jetzt freuen wir uns schon richtig
drauf und war noch nicht für tausende
sender ja genau sagen haben ist einfach
ungesund
wenn's schief geht werfen muss einfach
wieder raus ich hoffe natürlich nicht
wir werden jetzt erst einmal ein paar
sendungen machen und dann gucken wir
einfach also wir machen mal eine staffel
und dann gucken wir einfach dass uns
dabei gilt wirst im sender dabei geht
wie bei euch zuschauern ankommt und ich
denke das wird mir ganz coole geschichte
und vor allem als es noch gar nicht
gegeben
ja darum einfach so aus von zu hause aus
aber sowas ist studios live aus dem
riesengroßen parkhäuser aus der
metropolregion hier in baden
ja also ich wollte eigentlich die
sendung entstand starten wird unser haus
steht dass ich dann eben eine größere
küche habe das reißt uns leider nicht
denn wir würden gerne jetzt im winter
schon damit starten
das heißt so wachse dauer wenn alle zu
hause sitzen und gerne leckere kuchen
und fahrten von draxler ist gut ich mir
schon september aber aber so ein
bisschen besser so ungefähr
warum genau und jetzt freuen wir uns
darauf hoffe ich hoffe dass ihr euch
auch freud und demnächst gibt es dann
noch ein paar weitere inhaltsstoffe
nein ich hoffe wir haben nicht so viele
verstanden wird erklärt bevor ich euch
einfach nur kurz berichten und ja
einfach wir können einfach so bleiben
diese sind dann natürlich ganz arbeitet
sagen lasst die anderen sich verändern
und wie du bist also bleiben wir und bis
zum nächsten mal alkohol um 22 uhr
müssen erklären genau da gibt's dann
ganz genau was und farbband binären info
brauchen wir euch auch mal machst du ja
also ich nicht ich kann nicht wahr sein
wer mich raus